welcome to another Dr Sadler's honest
reviews this is a series in which I take
a close and unvarnished look at new and
sometimes older Works in philosophy very
broadly speaking so including applied
philosophy and ethics and the overlaps
between philosophy and psychology but
also self-help leadership personal
development and in this case education
the book that I'm reviewing this time is
indeed by an educator and it's geared
towards Educators it is called calm and
curious mindfulness stoicism and
philosophy for the modern classroom and
it's by Tim Iverson who has a long
history as a teacher so we're going to
do what we usually do we're going to
talk first about the three s's then
we'll go over some of the main points
the kind of bleed into each other we'll
talk about the good points about the
work and anything that I found
problematic about the book as well
so the three s's are style structure and
summary and let's begin with the summary
part this is a very short book it comes
in at around 96 pages total it's billed
as a handbook as a matter of fact it
says so at the very beginning on page
one in this handbook I'll share many of
the methods I learned and practiced over
the years I'll share some new ones I
created they range from short
mindfulness techniques to full-blown
lessons from philosophy and stoic
psychology as well as tips on self-care
for teachers and it concludes with a
list of resources you may find helpful
so I mean what Iverson is doing there is
giving you an overview and kind of a
summary of what the book is if you had
to put it in just a few terms you could
say the book is intended to convey to
Educators but perhaps also to a broader
public I think this is more
readable than just within the field of
Education some of the basics about as he
said stoic psychology and philosophy and
where these interconnect with other
let's call them fellow Travelers you
know mindfulness
Buddhism
the cognitive approaches in Psychology
emotional intelligence a few other
things get mentioned in there as well
and it is a very practically oriented
book the bulk of it is actually you
could call them lessons or practices or
advice if you want that a person could
begin using right away within the
classroom and with students and I you
know Elementary Middle High School
students but I think you could also use
this for college students or in adult
education as well and and get some good
results so that's what the book is
intended to do and I mean if you think
about the title itself calm and curious
so the mindfulness aspect or in you know
stoicism
uh you know attentiveness is supposed to
help us to be more calm both as teachers
and as Learners and you know as
communicators together but not to stifle
curiosity rather to open up the door to
Greater curiosity so I would say that's
a decent summary of the book the
structure itself it's divided up into a
number of different chapters we have an
introduction wisdom from ancient sources
where Iverson is telling us a bit about
you know what stoicism is and what
mindfulness is and how we can put these
together and whether we have to be
committed to any particular tradition in
a substantive way the answer is no
then we have mindfulness strategies uh
some discussion why mindfulness what's
the point behind it eight practices to
get you started the book is full of
practices exercises whatever you want to
call them then the next chapter stoic
inspired activities again eight lessons
to you know get you going these talking
about various aspects of stoic
philosophy the next chapter uh because
the the third one is actually quite long
you know if you think about it it's
actually occupying about a third of the
book the next one is mind mapping and
there's some actual mind maps in there
that are illustrating it and then a very
interesting chapter self-care tools for
teachers probably
more needed at this point in time than
at any other within our lifetimes given
all the stressors that teachers go
through and then finally we have this
interesting mindfulness scripts for the
classroom
um five practical scripts which can be
read aloud and used as an exercise in
the classroom and then we have this
resources for further study and a very
short acknowledgments the resources are
actually just two pages as well and one
feature I would like to point out so
each chapter begins with something kind
of cool there's you know in large script
there is this discussion in this case
mind mapping I discovered the art of
Mind mapping early in my career as a
visual arts teacher it was often a
perfect way for me to organize a complex
topic and for a classroom projects it
was lots of fun and most students could
be successful on some level mind mapping
as a way to make a topic easier to wade
into organize and it's visually
attractive okay so there's a little
description about what the chapter is
about but you notice there's also this
this artwork and that's kind of a cool
feature of it there's also artwork like
this that you see where it's kind of
cartoonish
drawn with pencils and and uh you know
illustrating things lots of terms and
and that sort of thing kind of like a
mind map right
so the only other thing we need to talk
about is
um style so it's written very much to be
something like a handbook lots of little
short sections that you can read and
come back to they're all organized you
know more or less and you know you can
go to and from them it's such a short
book that you you could easily you know
read it in
an hour or two and then you know give it
a second re-read if you wanted to and
you could bring this it could be a
Handbook look at how it fits in my hand
as well so that's probably enough about
the big uh you know three S's
all right so main ideas of the work
we've already discussed a few of them
one that is running throughout the
entire work basically as a
presupposition for its very existence is
that
stoicism along with some other things
that are similar to or connected with it
can be very helpful in education in the
classroom for students for teachers and
help to incrementally not not all at
once like flipping a switch but
cumulatively
improve education as a process for the
adults and for the children who are
involved in it and I think that's
actually quite true I think there's a
great room for incorporating stoicism
and other philosophical approaches and
other wisdom approaches
through practices into the the classroom
and the way in which it uh works and
Iverson is actually quite good I think
in making sure that people understand
you don't have to be a Buddhist you
don't have to like buy into stoicism
Wholesale in order to get something out
of this and that education is not the
same thing say as you know cognitive
behavior therapy right although aspects
of CBT or rebt or DBT or other things
can be quite useful in that uh that
domain right so stoicism mindfulness is
applicable to teaching and learning to
students I also do like that inclusion
of the support for teachers all too
often we frame education as if it's you
know it's all about the students and we
forget that the teachers are the ones
who are are at the interface of
everything there's not just students and
parents and you know other stakeholders
if we're teaching them anything that
vast body of knowledge that is hopefully
trickling into students heads to some
degree is largely coming through what it
is that teachers do so if we can help
teachers to teach more effectively and
to have you know more resilience in
dealing with the many challenges that
arise well that that's actually quite
good and I think that this book could be
you know quite helpful for that I I do
you know think that it's laid out well
here
um you know the lessons activities
practices scripts those are all
providing you with a pretty rich content
that you could use as an educator or
even just on yourself to try to improve
your own educational experience so those
are I would say the main ideas
involved in this work I would say maybe
one other one is that you don't have to
pick and choose in the sense of I belong
to this team or I belong to this team a
sort of eclectic let's see what actually
works and where things come together
approach is what is is underlying this
as well which I think is a good point so
that's a great transition to talk about
what I found particularly good about
this book
so I do in fact have a lot of good
things to say about this book and the
first is that I really like the fact
that it has
so many whatever you want to call them
exercises practices
lessons scripts all of those sort of
things that can be done rather than just
simply red so it's a it's a book for
doing right and but it's it's
intelligent doing it's not just hey
let's let's jump in here and here's a
bunch of menus and recipes no no it's
it's very thoughtful and I think that
it's um
pretty well done in how these are
connected with each other and aligned
with each other so that that's a good
point about the book I will also say on
an aesthetic point that one of the
things I like the most about this book
are all of these
pictures
these artworks at the beginning of the
chapter and so I'll just show you
several others as well this is probably
my favorite one right here it's very
beautiful isn't it and then we have
another one that I believe I've already
shown you but I'll show it to you one
more time because you know why why
shouldn't we have more and more Beauty
in our life right this is something that
I think particularly in terms of
stoicism often overlooked my second
favorite one right here and then do we
have one before the yeah we do have one
here's the mindfulness one I'm wondering
whether we have one before the resources
and the answer unfortunately is no but
that's already quite a lot right there
I'm not as big of a fan I have to admit
of the drawings
um like these but some people might
actually enjoy that right So Different
Strokes for different folks as we often
say another thing that I think is
actually a strength of the work is that
Iverson very clearly is drawing upon you
know several decades of experience
with uh teaching and with bringing these
sorts of things into the classroom it's
you know grounded in stoic philosophy in
a way that I think is is quite helpful
it's not just a let's jump on the
stoicism bandwagon as we see with oh so
many books right this is uh one that's
kind of ripened over time I would say
as I mentioned earlier this could easily
be useful for people of all different
walks of life it doesn't necessarily
have to be about education although you
know that is definitely the theme and I
think that anybody could pick up this
book and I get quite a bit out of it and
apply some of these things within the
scope of their own practice in life and
and work so those are some good things I
I would also like to single out one
particular lesson that I thought was
really quite cool seeing and describing
objectively through ART and you know
it's got some stuff in here about
objectivity that I'm not sure I
completely buy into but I really like
this exercise this activity of having
the students looking at a piece of art
and
um you know looking at it mindfully kind
of dwelling on it thinking through it
describe vibing it then adding in
judgments stories inferences likes or
dislikes and this part about extension
as well so I think you know there's a
lot of cool lessons in here I think that
that one's particularly good I also did
like the uh the reference and discussion
about the three C's moving to the four
C's he brings up commitment control and
Challenge and that each of these is you
know something important uh how how does
he incorporate these and then he talks
about the fourth C coaching a good
school system provides lots of
opportunities for mentoring and
communication between veterans and newer
teachers he says well that's that's
really good and that's something that I
think we should stress is important you
don't just like get your degree and do
your student teaching and then get
thrown into the classroom and boom now
you're doing great no education is
something that you need to work on over
time and it helps to draw upon other
people's experience and Reflections and
what worked and what didn't work and all
of that so there's you know quite a lot
of things that I do in fact like about
this work
there are a few things that I did find
problematic about this work none of
which I would say are like intrinsically
bad or anything or rise to the level of
you know misinforming the reader or
anything along those lines but there
were some things where I think you know
maybe there there could be a few
problems one is
it could have used a bit more editing
and you know I'm I'm hesitant to say too
much about this uh because it's easy to
get these things wrong but at one point
in the work Donald Roberts and here it
is on page 75 stoic author Donald
Roberson calls this emotional acceptance
you notice there's a t missing there and
it's actually there in the resources for
further study where Donald Roberts Sons
how to think like a Roman Emperor is uh
brought up so I don't know how that
crept in there you know is is that too
big of an issue no but but it does show
somebody should have probably copy
edited this maybe a little bit more than
they they did
There's also points where I think that
the
presentation of certain Concepts can be
a bit misleading and uh you know that
would be a problem it'd be the sort of
thing where somebody reads more and then
they're like wait a second I thought
that Iverson said XYZ but now I'm
finding out that this is actually the
case and then somebody be like well yeah
he was oversimplifying there or not
giving you a full picture of things so
you know some of these have to do with
what we could call the modalities of
cognitive
Psychotherapy you know he he says at one
point very early on that CBT was
actually an offspring of stoicism
well no that's not actually right
there's a longer more complicated story
there in which rebt rational motive
behavior therapy which again is not an
offshoot of stoicism but incorporate
some is their first and then CBT
cognitive behavior therapy is going to
come out of that so it's not an offshoot
from stoicism and as a matter of fact
most CBT people don't know much about
stoicism or even really about the
origins of their their discipline anyway
so that can be a little misleading
um calling rational emotive behavior
therapy a type of cognitive behavior
therapy which Iverson does on page eight
that's clearly wrong rebt and CBT are
not types of each other they're actually
you could say species within the larger
genus of cognitive approaches there's
definitely connections there but if you
wanted to talk about like the origins of
things rebt is first cognitive behavior
therapy comes after so rebt is not a
type of of cognitive behavior therapy
although it is a cognitive approach
um
there's a discussion about mindfulness
in the East and being tied to the
Eightfold Path it was part of an overall
training called the Eightfold Path well
that's a little misleading yes Buddhist
mindfulness is definitely part of the
Eightfold Path that is absolutely
Central to Buddhism the fourth Noble
Truth
but that's not all the mindfulness that
exists in non-western philosophy there's
this entire vast religion called
Hinduism in which mindfulness plays a
significant part and there's there's
others as well I mean we could talk
about taoism so it's not always tied to
the Eightfold Path again not completely
wrong but could be a little misleading
for readers who don't know that much
about it a similar kind of um little
mixing things up in terms of emotional
intelligence this is on page 15 Iverson
says mindfulness is also being seen as a
key component of emotional intelligence
E.I the field of emotional intelligence
sometimes abbreviated as EQ or emotional
quotient has grown over the last two
decades no EQ is one thing within the
scope of emotional intelligence it is
not what emotional intelligence is
abbreviated to so so I'm not quite sure
where that's that's coming from
um again is that going to like totally
mislead somebody no but it's you know
it's it's not good to get these things
wrong there's another thing specifically
about stoic philosophy that I thought is
a little bit off and that's this
discussion of the dichotomy and
trichotomy of control it is true as he
says that one of the foundational
concepts of stoicism is called the
dichotomy of control not called so by
Epictetus you would kind of get that
impression from this and he doesn't
actually explain
what is according to Epictetus in our
control and not in our control he just
said some things are within our power
others are not
um and so you know that's I think a
little bit of a problem and then he'll
tell us afterwards contemporary stoics
talk about the trichotomy of control the
the TOC recognizes there's gray areas
where we may be able to have some
influence on an outcome without having
total control well some stoics do for
example William Irvine does right but
that is an incredibly
controversial proposal within the realm
of modern stoicism and some people
really take uh
Irvine to task over that and you know
others like myself have pointed out that
the original dichotomy of control is way
more complicated than just what you find
in N Caribbean one and that the
trichotomy of control can kind of fit
into the original dichotomy of control
rightly understood you'd never get that
from from this so that's that's a little
bit of a problem I think
we also have a brief reference to maxims
I kind of wish that Iverson had said a
little bit more about this because I
mean he is right stoics called and he
says these meaning uh little you know
statements maxims and encourage students
to keep them ready to hand to
contemplate during difficult moments
are you sure is not a stoic Maxim that's
something that Iverson is coming up with
and it would be cool to see you know
some discussion of actual stoic maxims
and how useful or effective or important
they are given that it plays a major
role within stoic philosophy
um the last sort of quibble that I have
has to do with this lesson seven on
brain and mind
where you know it's things that are not
completely wrong again but it's
misleading right so there's vocabulary
terms the hegemony cone the Greek for
ruling faculty or Reason well it's a
Greek for ruling faculty or Reason in
stoic philosophy and in some other later
philosophies uh it's not you know the
ancient Greeks had a term hegemonicon
which meant ruling faculty are the part
that guides well some ancient Greeks did
Aristotle sure is held this right he's a
he's a pretty important ancient Greek
Socrates did and Plato didn't this is a
stoic idea right and it should have been
signaled as such and I don't think if we
if we're actually looking at ancient
stoicism it doesn't line up nicely with
the prefrontal cortex it's tempting very
often to you know want to frame things
in terms of the brain but if we're being
strict about this the hegemonicon is you
know it's pretty pretty vast what it
does in stoic philosophy it's the part
through which we actually feel things as
well as think things and decide things
it's not just the executive part that
Iverson is kind of turning it into here
he also brings up a you know proy racist
another Greek term for our faculty of
choice or Reason favored by Epictetus
well none of the stoics other than
Epictetus actually talk about the prior
racist it's an Aristotelian term
primarily that Epictetus brings into his
discussion turns into something bigger
than what Aristotle did makes its way
into neoplatonism it is uh and and you
know it's funny here because Epictetus
one can provide a good argument for this
that for Epictetus the the
hegemonicon the ruling part the rational
part the logica K right and the Prairie
racists are all actually the same thing
right so technically speaking Iverson
would be right to say
another Greek term for our faculty of
choice or reason right yes not the way
that most people using prior racists
actually used it among the Greeks
so kind of wrong and kind of misleading
um
and you know it's it should be noted
that uh
um again Epictetus is the main person to
talk about this even Marcus who loves
Epictetus doesn't really use this term
much so we want to be a little bit
cognizant and careful about this and
again these are all kind of quibbles you
could say the only other thing that I do
have to say is in the resources for
further study I found this you know at
least in the stoic part a little bit
disappointing
um you know Farnsworth the practicing
stoic I know a lot of people like that
book but it's basically just a bunch of
quotes all put under a certain number of
headings sometimes mistranslated I've
found in discussions with people who
brought them up so I wouldn't be quite
so eager to endorse that one
and I was you know quite surprised that
we get instead of the actual epic teeth
is just a reference to LaBelle's Art of
Living which is okay but
is actually a source of a lot of
misleading misquotations of Epictetus on
the internet there is no despite
referring a lot to Epictetus in this
he's not on one of the
um you know recommended works there's
the haze translations of Marcus
aurelius's meditations which is decent
then there's seneca's letters from A
stoic the penguin Edition from 1969
we've got more recent additions uh
including you know the much better
University of Chicago one which is what
I would actually recommend letters on
ethics if we're going to do that
um and then you know there's a few other
people being recommended in here who I I
have no problem with you know Donald
Robertson and pigliucci and Lopez
um you know Chris Fisher's little
article on Pros okay
but is this if I were putting this into
somebody's hands and say hey if you want
to like learn about stoicism these are
the recommended texts I think it could
have been a little bit better put
together so those are again all kind of
at the level of quibbles not like
damning condemnations of the work there
is a lot that I think is quite good
about this but there are these
problematic aspects as well
all right so my final thoughts about
this work I'm I endorse it I think it's
uh pretty good
um I've mentioned a few things that I
think could be you know a little bit
misleading but those are not big deals
and there's so much that's quite good
about this book that I recommend it and
think that it would be you know decent
to get your hands on and to read your
way through as I mentioned it's a very
quick read well written easy to make
your way through this could be a decent
uh starting point for I think a lot of
people and this could be quite useful
for many teachers and even school
districts so yeah I'm quite happy with
this work I'm glad that uh Iverson sent
me a copy and I recommend it to you